each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure to welcome cm11 from
pohang university of science and
technology and she actually received a
master and PhD from university of
illinois in chicago champagne and a few
years ago she did internship at
microsoft research and today she's going
to talk to us about what we can learn
from the wisdom of crowds of also for
development its fiscal
thank you for the introduction okay
today my name is sing one and today I'd
like to talk about my recent work on
software code search and this is joint
work with the professor song came at
home from ust and also my students at
postech which names listed here okay so
before we start I'll show you where I'm
from so I'm from postech which is
located in the city of poem so as you
can see from the map point is on the
southeast part of Korea and we are
rather a young school we are about 20
years old and we get about 300 300
undergrads every year over 20 partners
in engineering and science that's
geographically speaking where I'm from
and academically speaking I'm coming
from search and database field since
most of you are not coming from that
field I think I'll spend some time in
the beginning of the talk to explain a
little bit about my background and also
as Tom introduced oh I see a lot of
interns here and I did my internship
here about six years ago I spent two
very wonderful summers at the DMX group
so it's actually a homecoming for me and
I'm very happy to be here okay so this
is the outline I'll first talk about a
search problem in general and later I
will talk about how those components in
search driven approaches can be used to
help software developers okay are in a
very simplified summary the search
problem is about finding the right
result for the given user right away so
usually that is very tricky because the
search usually deals with a very large
search corpus so for instance the corpus
for search engine is billions and
billions of documents so a very popular
analogy for finding the right document
among those heap of billions of document
is like finding a needle in the haystack
so here in this figure this person could
use 65,000 second to find his needle but
usually as we all
the users for search applications are
not that patient so we have to find the
result within a second or within a point
one second so doing doing these tooth
task is usually very challenging so
because of that there has been a very
rich body of research for the search
especially dealing with the hay stack of
documents and for today you can imagine
a big haystack a consisted of software
code so I'll say a little bit more about
those two main task so first about
defining the right result it could be
tricky because users do not often fully
express what they need as Curie so to
give you example this user here is
looking for our good camera for his work
and someone says nikon d3x is good so he
sent that as accurate to ping and get
these result then it is possible that
this user is fully satisfied with being
result meanwhile there could be another
user of sending out the same curie with
a slightly different search intent then
it is also likely that the same result
for nikon d3x might not be that
satisfied that is buying for the second
users so because of this challenge there
have been two different approaches to
tackle this challenge first is
personalization so in this approach we
are trying to figure out what's hidden
the hidden intent in the curie and try
to optimize the result differently for
different users even though they share
the same curie keyword so that is one
way which would be very effective if
your prediction of search intent is
correct but often times you cannot
predict that accurately in which case
the personalization could be a somewhat
risky so for that case there could be
another approach of diversifying the
result to show a little bit of
everything that can make different
people happy so that well it's not like
making one person extremely happy but
all the users are still not happy so in
a way the goal of diversification is
minimized that this satisfaction in case
the pretty
action was wrong so forth love so no
matter which way you take our interest
is finding the right result within
second so there has been a lot of
research on finding those right result
for the personalization and
diversification so there are many
research questions related to that and
actually all my past research and
ongoing research falls into somewhere in
this slide so for instance for
personalization what we have to do is
you have to figure out what user wants
the heat and intent based on user
behaviors and so on we have to mine out
what specific about this user and for
instance in being if they figure out
from the Curie that this user is likely
to buy this camera they will show you
this nice summary summarizing the
customer reviews and the price range of
the products out there so that the user
can go to the best deal right away so
you can guess or predict or mind those
intense and then personalize the result
so for that to return the result right
away you need efficient algorithms to
optimize the cost for computing
different result for different people so
I have been working on those algorithms
and also another for another direction
or you can do is like the curie keyword
jaguar which could be in different
things for different users some people
mean jaguar the cat jaguar the car
jaguar the kid came in if you cannot
know which jaguar this user means what
you can do is categorize the result
based on different intents and show that
these category as a guidance so that
people with different intents can go to
the category of their interest and be
satisfied so for that there are also
many research question like what kinds
of categories are most effective for
most users so how to compute those
categories and also algorithms to
cluster result efficiently so instead of
going through the details I will just
close the first part of my talk by
showing I'll just
one example because I sleep example is
often better than many words so this
example demo is what we built together
with Microsoft Research Asia during the
visit of myself and my student so like
for the product kure that I showed
before what being does is to show the
product specific information for the
given kure so they show the summary for
just one camera but what we want you to
do is to show the related camera grouped
representing different user intense so
the first user interested in work camera
can go for this group and another user
looking for is a vacation camera can go
to that that group and you can figure
out the relationship between two camera
by moving over the mouse and then if you
click some camera that you are
interested in then that will be the new
center so that's so here is one example
of diversification and for that for
grouping their data into the cluster
that represent different groups of
search intense what we need to do first
is to extract the product features from
the web like the resolution of camera
price and so on then what we need to do
is to define the similarity similarity
and here in order for the
diversification like this to be
successful those similarity measure
should reflect the actual human
perception of the product similarity so
for that what we use is use is
collective intelligence of people who
write reviews on the web so for instance
if one person writes a review comparing
camera a and B that is a one indication
that these human being think these two
cameras are related in somehow somehow
if you collect those Cochran's is from 1
million say product review that would be
another indication of the perceived
similarity matrix we can obtain from the
user so here what we did is to combine
the similarity we extracted from data
and the similarity save truth product
sharing similar feature values are
similar
and another notion of similarity from
the people's people's perception and
then we combine them to compute those to
organize the result like that so in Kate
for details if you are interested in if
you are attending the faculties of it
next week you can find us that demo fest
ok so I think that was a very very brief
overview of the search research in
general but I'm hoping that you can now
see why I would be interested in the big
pile of software code as a researcher
nowadays it is very cheap and easy to
collect a large pile of code corpus I
can easily build a corpus of the coast
that I have ever written and maybe I can
use that for writing my own code because
there are recurring patterns from my my
code writing or I for Microsoft I think
I'm sure they have a large code base of
archiving the codes ever written in the
microsoft and you can easily do that if
you want to and even collecting the
source code available worldwide is not
that hard you can crawl all the source
code and make this big heap now the
question is what can we do with this hip
this hip has lots of potential because
that I believe is representing the
wisdom of say my wisdom of Microsoft
developers or my curse or the wisdom of
the developers that has ever existed in
the planet so if there is a good search
engine on top of it then for instance
when I'm trying to teach myself some new
API then it is likely that there is
someone else who went through the exact
same process and already know a lot of a
lot about it so if good search engine
can connect me to that person or the
code he wrote I can definitely learn a
lot from that and also when I'm about to
devising a new code then also it is
likely that somewhere in the universe or
in the past won't eat the same
functionality and did something about it
so if there is a
search on that then maybe you can avoid
reinventing the wheel so that's the
vision I have and I believe there can be
many different types of right search
engines we can build but in the second
part of the talk I will introduce one
example search engine that we built on
the code corpus ok so there has been
many past research saying observing
developers do look at the lots of
resources on the web and they take
advantage of that during their
development so if I don't almost need to
motivate the need for building the right
search engines for those resources and
those resources include say api
documents explaining what each method
does our inputs and outputs are so here
the exempt this is example document for
java and a lot of time there was
research also observing that the
developers often look for example to see
how these api is actually used because
we developers often find reading english
is harder than reading this complicated
code so we make a few more search
requests to until we we hit the high
quality examples and then we fully
understand what the api does so based on
that what we can think is that if you
can combine of very high quality
documents with the high quality examples
then that will be a very useful
resources for the developers and I'm not
alone to think that because there do
exist lots of resources combining high
quality documents an example and msdn is
a good example well where the human
technical writers are right height high
quality documents and they also for each
documents they have nice handcrafted
example that there are designed to
explain the given API so msdn as you
know is a high quality resource examples
and you can think of books that you buy
to teach yourself pythons c-sharp which
is filled with those examples and
usually come with the CD or dvd
it stores all those code examples so
that you can learn from that you can run
it or play with it to figure out how to
program so this is a actually the hight
school at the high quality resources
that we are targeting too but only one
downside is that here users have to
handcraft those examples so it involves
human labor so these resources are rare
and expensive and in reality most of API
documents are generated automatically
from the code using the tool like Java
Docs which extract the documents from
the code and comment so with those
extraction tools those documents are
inherently lacking of good example so
from our observation we found that from
the document for Java only two percent
of the API has the examples so what we
wanted to do is build a system that some
ng search engines so that if you specify
some API name this will search for the
open source code base to find find the
actual source code that is using those
API and then we extract the high-quality
examples out of it and then
automatically embed it in the say
example this document like Java doc so
in a way a java document so in a way our
goal is to our question is whether we
can automatically generate msdn quality
documents using the open source code
base okay so one immediate solution that
you can think of is using existing code
search products there is a product from
google and there is coders calm and we
found out that the search engine results
are not suitable for our our goal
because to show you that this is the
result we get from the curie connection
prepared statement and for this system
we are hoping those summary will show
how those API is called and so on but
usually the top result from those two
code search engines
are just supporting keyword search so
they will show whatever wear whatever
the match in the code usually here there
is the keyword connection so the top
result will show the comment line
mentioning the connector word connection
or import statement mentioning
connection or some random part
mentioning the word connection so based
on those example you cannot really learn
a lot about those API and our goal is
producing so it's a msdn quality example
so for that to define what's good
examples we need to observe the
handcrafted examples from the msdn so
what's so great about those hand
handcrafted examples so the first thing
is that these example is showing
different usage types so it's related to
the diversification that I mentioned in
the beginning of the talk so based on
API name we don't know what type this
user would be interested in so we will
show a different usage type so for this
is an example for list insert so this
API can be called with two argument
three arguments or array as an argument
and so on so by looking at it you can
teach yourself different usage types and
another virtue of this handcrafted
example is that this is very concise so
this code is specifically designed to
teach you these api so no line here is
irrelevant for the api you are about to
learn they are there to serve the
purpose of teaching you this api so
usually we do not have this luxury if we
are extracting example from the actual
code because that code is written for
different purpose of serving whatever
the product project the best so that
will contain lots of part that are not
related to the API of your interest and
so on so which suggests that for our
system to be effective that should be
able to summarize to get rid of all the
relevant part and save only the part
save only the part that can explain the
API so the good so if there are more
than one candidates that
be married to the Curie then we will
need some kind of ranking to pick the
most high-quality example for documents
so that is what we need and another
interesting thing with the high the
handcrafted example here is that they
are showing some semantic context so
they for engler to understand the api
api call is not everything that you need
to learn there is something more so for
instance like you need to know how these
argument is declared and populated so
good example often include those
semantic context as well so inspired by
those handcrafted example this is the
system that we design so we name the
system XY for example oriented API
document so first we start with example
lists document like document for Java
which has only 8 examples for two
percent of the API and for each API in
the documents will search the open
source code repository to pick the
candidates code that actually calls
those API and the next step is
summarizing them to get rid of all the
semantically relevant part and keep only
those semantic context that is related
to that API call and then the second
part is grouping them into clusters
representing different types of usages
so we'll have a group of code examples
and the last part is that among each
group will elect the representative that
best shows the each group so for each
cluster will elect one representative
which will embed to the documents to
create xof so we'll take a look at those
each each of those three steps one by
one here so first of all summarization
the summarization we saw for the
snippets of course calm is just based on
textual vicinity so they will find
whatever the occurrence of the keyword
in the code and show say two lines
before there are two lines after that so
we as developers all know that
those adjacent lines may or may not
automatically relevant so what we do is
to analyze code semantically by parsing
them and figuring out the dependency
between the lines to keep only the lines
that are semantically relevant so for
instance declaring the argument or
changing the values of argument or
declaring the class of API so we'll
summarize like that and then we'll have
a corpus of summarized codes and the
next step we do is cluster them to
groups representing different types so
as I show with the product clustering
examples for good clustering you need to
define good similarity function and
natural choice would be using some kind
of tree similar tree similarity measure
because code is a tree but there are
actually many tree similarity measures
like tree at the distance and so on but
these metrics are usually very expensive
so people usually approximate those tree
as a vector and then compare the vectors
so in the research for detecting clones
software close the approximation that
that they used is something like this
for the given code we get the parse tree
and we sort of we flatten them into the
vector by showing what types of elements
are there and how many are there so for
instance these tree can be summarized by
two blue nodes 1 green node and two gray
node and two white notes so you flatten
the tree like as a vector like that and
once you do that so this is what these
factories are often called in those
software code detection research as a
characteristic vectors which was
proposed in for the deck Kart clone
detection tool so once we vectorized
like that then now your code corpus is a
numerical data base so you can apply any
existing clustering algorithms for
clustering like k-means but here we have
additional challenge which is that the
right number of clusters
a can be different from different API
some API has a single usage type some
API has many different usage of type so
whatever the costume algorithm you use
that should be able to find out the
right number of clusters and adapt the
clustering for differently for different
API so that's the additional challenge
okay the last part is ranking so now we
have a group of example code
representing different usage types and
we have to pick a good example to really
embed it to documents for that we will
elect representative for each group so
as a criteria or features for such
rankings we are using those three those
three factors first a good example
should be representative should well
represent the group it belongs to and
the second criteria is line of code
conciseness if your example is very
short and concise it will be easier to
read and then third part we are checking
the type matching so the in the java
document they are specifying the type of
class and arguments so among those
examples will prefer the example that
matches the type of argument in class so
we need to so we can be based on those
criteria we can quantify the score and
then we need to combine them into the
overall score to pick the example with
the highest overall score for the
documents and for aggregation as I
mentioned in the first part of the talk
if for aggregation to be good those
aggregation functions should well
represent the people perception of how
those features should be aggregated so
I'll show you what we can do for that
later okay so if you're interested then
you are invited to visit this x1 post
deck that is that KR where you can see
the actual automatically generated code
from this tool and here I'll show you
one example page to show what we can do
so from the Java a travel document what
we can first thing we can add in
this popularity bar because we know
which API is often used in the actual
open source project and also what we
could add is an of course an example and
as you can see from here the quality is
better than the just using the snippet
from coders now we are actually showing
the actual API call and say how those
argument is declared and another feature
here is where users can feedback about
the ranking so here you just can click
those buttons to promote or demote the
ranking and these are the feedbacks we
can collect and to determine or tune
those aggregation function for selecting
the right examples so we are currently
collecting those user feedback to see
how we can adapt the ranking okay so in
order to evaluate how good our
automatically generated documents are we
are asking two key question first of all
we want to know how our document
compares to other resources like Java
Docs or what we can get from source code
engine the second question is whether
this can help software developer so I'll
first talk about the first question so
when comparing to the javadocs like I
mentioned in for the previous slide the
original javadocs only has examples for
the two percent of the API and after
this generation process we could find
examples for seventy-five percent of the
API for Java and we can also compare
with the Google encoders compared to
using those quarters snippets as
examples for XO documents or the
probability that our summary contains
both API calls and always semantic
context context is about ninety two
percent and four quarters and google
that probabilities of twenty two percent
or twelve percent because they are doing
supporting the keyword
search so this is how we can compare to
those google and coders result and also
we can compare to human ranking so what
we did is we to human ancestors we give
the k result k example that we found
from EXO ah and the k random result k
random result and present those two k
result to the human ancestors and make
them pick the k better ones and using
those selected human selected k as the
ground truth we could measure the
precision and recall which was sixty-six
percent and sixty percent respectively
and for the second question of whether
these tool is useful for the developers
we also gave out those documents blindly
to 24 human subjects the half of them
got actual document and half of them God
Java documents and we asked them to do
the fourth task related to the database
like establishing a connection creating
the sequel scape Damon send them and
then get the result and we are measure
the average completion time for two
groups and the average number of
document lookups and we found out that
the completion time was uh so the extra
group could complete the task or with
less time and also for document look up
XO group in average took bit only the
five documents while that number would
be three times higher for Java Docs and
among those look up some of them are
redundant and only three out of five is
distinct pages however that ratio is
much lower for Java Docs which means
javadocs group looking at the same
documents over and over again and among
those distinct page most of them are
relevant for extra group and that ratio
is again lower for the java documents so
that was the result for a brief users
study for extra documents
okay so that was the first part of talk
and that more details can be found from
triple-a I paper we wrote about this
engine and the second part is about how
whether we can support those code search
fast and let me motivate that by showing
some video actually this is the video
from Stanford HD HDI group showing
proposing a new developer environment so
what they propose is during their
development they can look for the
information about API so the result is
like what we saw in the XO a document
plus example but by looking at them they
can learn about those API and continue
develop development and if some of those
examples are actually what you want to
do then you can just copy and paste it
to the to the code so I think this is
the system called blueprint proposed
from the Stanford and what they are
showing is that if some code example
good code examples or relevant Cody
informations are available then those
look up and the development can be
interleaved to really change the
programming practices and I'm also
interested in those interleaving a
scenario where the search result should
be instant and actually as a search
researcher I'm interested in actually
interleaving every desktop task with the
search so that's one that's longer-term
vision so so I mean interested in to the
interleaving model because of two
reasons first as you can see from the
video your task whatever that is can be
benefited a lot from the search and also
the other direction is true the search
can be much more personalized for you
much more accurate for you by using
whatever the task context test context
so here in the blueprint they are not
using much about the you're developing
context but I what I'm the problem i'm
interested in is using that to
get the result search results that are
personalized for your development
context and I believe if this can be
done very accurately well that will
probably complete your next line if they
can find what they can understand what
you are doing and then they can find
search the right corpus why not so
that's what we want to do and then for
development context there could be a lot
of different thing well in the blueprint
work they considered the fact that this
programmer is developing in flex with
virgin x.x point X so they are adding
that to the curie in a way to adapt to
the search context that develop pink
development context and there could be a
lot more different kinds of context like
for the second part of talk we consider
the code developed so far and then find
the existing code that share does those
part with similar part for the code
developed so far and there can be even
many more like what kinds of
communication they had in the team and
so on as those task so here assume let's
assume we are using the code developed
so far as such task and try to look for
the clones close during the development
and there do exist lots of research so
there are lots of cone detection tools
but they do not talk much about getting
the result fast because they didn't need
to because the scenario they are
interested is rather offline such as
well while you are heading home you can
run your code detector could clone
detector and then tomorrow morning you
come back and see groups of code that
share that are clones and then tomorrow
you can do something about it to two
different groups so the scenario they
are targeting is offline so they do not
discuss much about making that online or
instant but um but and meanwhile the
code search engine does support online
with online search you can get the
result within point one second but as
you could see there
are not considering the semantic part so
for the goal what we want you to do is
to combine the strengths of both to
support online semantic clones that the
finding online clone detector that cuz
considers a structural similarity and I
believe they can open up many
interesting opportunities because right
now the clone detection model is sum up
I named post-mortem in a sense that you
let the clones happen and do something
about later but if we can support that
the structural connection tool online
and even interleave with your
development session then your coat and
detection could be more preventive like
when you are about to generate a cone
you will know what kinds of cones are
there right away and or based on that
you can also get the personalized search
you will search your stack of hay stack
of code and sharing the same part same
part of the code that you develop so far
so that you can use those Colin
detection in a more preventive and
personalized way so the goal is to
support contradiction using structural
similarity online which is complementing
the current state of ours ok so for code
representation I'm for this work i'm
using the same characteristic vectors
idea but for the given context the match
could be happen in any part of the tree
at any granularity so we cannot generate
we cannot represent a tree with a single
vector so instead we'll generate thus
all the sub trees with sighs at least
some tea so our code will be a set of
vectors ok so with that well we want to
find the top five top ten top kek loans
fast and a very live way to do that is
given curie you will compare each and
every code in your corpus and rank them
but what we want to do is
make it fast to avoid looking at every
every code in the code base instead you
can build some nice index structure or
date data structure so that you can
access only the part of the code base
that are likely to be high scoring and
then rank them yep so the life way you
can do it is now that after generating
characteristic vectors out of it now you
have numerical vector so you can build a
multi-dimensional index on your database
and then search with the keurig code
however there is a well-known problem in
data mining called curse of
dimensionality so if your vector has
dimensionality over a certain number
then building those index cannot save
you much compared to the naive solution
of accessing everything and comparing
with everything so what we can do is
reduce the dimensionality for the data
and build the index on those reduced
data space and when the curious given
you will reduce the curie in the same
way and send the reduced version of kira
code to the index to find clones so that
way you can bypass the curse of
dimensionality problem but you have a
additional problem that the result you
get is not no longer accurate instead
you can get a larger set of result of
candidates so that will be the step one
and now you will need extra step to get
the data get the original data of those
candidates and rank them so now your
step need to be two steps so this big
approach this highlight high level
approach is well known in the database
community as gemini for generate
generalized multimedia indexing so often
those multimedia databases have this
high dimensionality problem so different
systems though the details could vary
the highest a lot of our existing
multimedia database system use those
high-level techniques of reducing the
data in
both kure to get the candidates first
then narrow down to the right result
later so the for the first step of
dimensionality reduction you will have
two goals first you want to ensure the
correctness for that your candidate from
the step one should be guaranteed to
contain all the right result so for that
you need to ensure that thus the
distance between to code in the reduced
space should be smaller than or equal to
the distance in the original space and
also in order to ensure efficiency of
how much you need to access to get the
top-k result in order for that to be
small you're the distance in the reduced
space should preserve that the distance
relationship in the original space as
much as possible so here the Delta is
quantifying those these differences in
terms of distances so now you need to
find those the way to reduce the
dimensionality pursuing the stones both
goals and that problem is known as
np-hard so in the paper we are
developing a greedy approximation scheme
so the detail i'll skip it for today's
talk so once dimensionality is reduced
for instance if your code is reduced to
the two dimensional data then your code
is like a point now a point in the two
dimensional data space then you can
build some index structure on it and
there are many multi dimensional index
structures you can use and one of the
well-known tree structure is our tree
what it does is grouping those points
there are nearby as a bounding
rectangles and then that will be the
tree node like this and then those
rectangle rectangles are hierarchically
organized until every code is a one
rectangles then what's great about doing
this is that once the curious given
again the Curie will be another two
dimensional point then we need to access
the candidates around the security point
and once we build those index structure
to accessing those candidates
we'll be very efficient by only
accessing the rectangles that contain
those search parameter so you can just
access those three node and get all the
potential top result so we will build
the archery index and then there are
many of the shelf archery implementation
on the web which you can use however we
found out that the performance of those
often shelf implementation was not
efficient enough so what we did is we
designed our own algorithm for building
index and traversing the index the for
instance for building index we know what
kinds of fury work clothes are to get
the candidates for a software search so
we can use those knowledge to group
together the candidates that are likely
to be accessed together to incur much
less I or cost and for trevor's
traversal to get to the candidates a
classic approach will be the two-step
approach so you traverse index first to
get the candidate boundary and then you
traverse that index again to get the
original data of those candidates and
then rank it what we propose in this
paper is to combine those two steps into
one we call that interleaved so if you
do that the obvious advantage will be
avoiding those redundant the second
index traversal but there is actually
the downside of it as well because only
after you are done with the entire
filtering step you know the exact
candidate boundary but if you try to get
the original data during those filtering
if you try to interleave those two steps
then the candidate bound do you know
during those filtering phase is actually
overestimation of candidate boundary so
you will need to access a few more extra
candidate candidates which will incur
extra cost so there is plus and minus
and what we did is that well now our
search range is larger but we can design
the Myo optimization technique so that
the larger requests extra cost for
larger requests can be minimized by
amortize in those
I accost so adding pluses and minuses
overall we found this interleaving
strategy was most efficient so that is
our winner strategy and also these two
algorithms are exact clone detection but
often you can those often ranking is
some a tolerant to a little bit of
approximation so if you are application
can tolerate some loss in terms of
accuracy then you can also approximate
which is we are also developing we are
also proposing an approximation
algorithm which is 20 to 30 times faster
if you can allow twenty twenty percent
loss in terms of precision so those are
the algorithm so what we did is we build
the code corpus out of JDK and the four
hundred open Java open source projects
we collected from the web and we first
generated characteristic vectors using
the existing tool that is used for other
co offline coin detection and for
building those indexes for those open
source corpus the time can takes the
building those index can take anywhere
from 0.5 seconds to about 2 minutes but
however what we want one to stress here
is that index is built once and then can
you can be used over and over for
different Curie's so that will be built
offline and will be used over and over
for different curious so what we want to
make it instant is actually this curing
time so this is comparing the curing
time for say up to 1.6 million vectors
and when we are looking for top when we
are retrieving top 20 result and
compared to the scan the interleaving so
the second line is the two-step approach
and the third line is interleaving
algorithm and the interleaving algorithm
is about 40 times up to 40 times faster
and the curing time is within the range
of one second or point one second which
one was the
range we were targeting too and also we
did take the same experiment for over
different K depending on how many top
result we are retrieving and we again we
are much faster than scan and well scale
over increasing k and also we also
compared with LSA with at fh which is
used by the card tool and we also
observed that our winning the archie
based algorithm is about 40 times faster
than the existing tool and here the
missing points for LLS h is because of
the knots of insufficient memory we
couldn't get the data point for that
with the system setting we have and we
are were about 40 times faster compared
to the existing tool ok so with that I
want to conclude this talk the truth is
top what I wanted to say is that we can
apply many search driven approaches to
contribute to software development
process and for the first paper we found
out that we can use search techniques
and open source code base to extract
high-quality example that can help
developers learn how to use those api's
and also i'm interested in making those
semantic code search as interact instant
and so that we can interact those look
up sessions with development and i think
there are many open questions we are
using characteristic vector
representation but obviously there can
be many many different ways to represent
more semantics from the code like the
structural info or or static analysis or
so on and another thing is that i know
that the code is a very ordinary small
part of the haystacks that you generate
during the software development and I
know there are lots of information that
software development generate and also
look up like related to box test
specifications
or there are a lots of communication
from people like in the forum email
chatting and so on but there are many
different types of software stack which
is interesting for the search researcher
and also all those haystacks are
interacting closely interacting which is
again more very interesting and
eventually I'm interested in if this
search can be really accurate and fast
I'm interested in whether those AI like
vision of your tool completing your code
for you is feasible so in the longer
term I'm interested in seeing that so
those are the open questions and I
believe this is an interesting field
where experts from many different fields
can contribute like software engineering
HCI and I'm coming from data base and
search so with because of that I'm very
happy to get to meet those experts from
software engineering field and present
this work so I would be happy to get
inspired by your expertise through
questions and comments so that's what i
prepared and thanks for your attention
ok any questions comments so um I was a
little curious about how your your
characteristic vectorworks like so
essentially you use that as a sort of
distance metric between code examples
for the clustering step right so does so
are so two examples are sort of similar
if they have essentially sort of the
same frequency of notes in the asp s oh
that essentially
oh right as you said the characteristic
vector is a frequency for ranking we are
using right now we are using Euclidean
distance but there could be many
different distance function you can use
so like the first so the the ordering of
likes a statement soon wouldn't message
wouldn't factor in homewood in factoring
with a current Proxima midnight and and
any other question hey how do you choose
ok so what we do is we try out with
different case and there are also the
correlating metrics study for the
clustering so like well the goal of
clustering is to group them so that the
internal similarity in our inner group
similarities maximize and intergroup
similarities minimize so there is based
on those criteria we can sort of
quantifies how good the clustering
result that are so we try out different
K and pick the one with ya
i generating code samples
work in that area and one of the things
that I found when I was experimenting
was that a large open source databases
like
are often not very representative
actually
so if you say Google for how do i use an
ssl socket vs if you search
any of the approval any of these search
engines which are dominated by huge open
source Apache projects and stuff like
that you're much more likely to get well
here is the Apache special
implementation of SSL sockets that it
uses and smells super than you are if
you get google the top 1000 results will
be here's the one common thing that
and so it would be interesting to apply
these techniques not just to large data
but also the fragments of sample code
are the number one resource for
programmers
right I'm very interested to hear that
the corpus from google code search is
made a lot different from the what you
get from google the general search
engine so for this work right now we are
using the Google tool so if there is
such bias I think this will suffer the
same bias for in order to a different
way to do that is to build our own
crawler for that and another interesting
idea is that right now we are using
those actual we are extracting example
from the code but as you said we can
also write the crawler for the code
example that people write in the
software forum and so on we can just
extract them and I I think that would be
interesting as well in a sense that that
is developed for explaining something so
that will be likely to be more
instructive but the downside it is that
the coverage could be lower like the API
that is I don't know much much higher
higher Ilyas Oh are we done this
then especially for obscure things you
just won't get it
right oh I see okay so we follow the
paper oh I see I think okay then what we
can do is that we can crawl both
hand-crafted example on the web and also
the actual open source code and combine
them as the corpus and actually we
couldn't have a chance to compare those
two purposes but I'm interested in
comparing the two and compared to
coverage and pros and cons and once both
of them are collected as the corpus then
the remaining process will work more or
less the same so yeah that's what we can
do like when I do are searching for the
assembly code in the search engine right
and i often find now sort of simple code
on some countries and gigs or blocks but
the thing is you know i like their
samples but uh you know they have good
and kind of experiences right
introduction to be a little confusing
but there are several texts are very
useful but in Ottawa
writing hmm right so have you thought
about like incorporating sort of blog
information like their code and so
you're like search soldier block right
yeah I think those two questions are
related and that's what we want to do we
want there are also lots of social
resources forums these are interesting
thing to crawl and I believe the quality
will be very high so yeah I want that's
some of some of the future issues future
topic that I want to explore I think
both can be complementary to each other
and I want to learn more about the
information for the taxi so it is very
important text as well yeah for
summarization technique the same
technique can be used for a code for
text I think we can borrow some ideas
from NLP they are doing lots of
summarization so we can try to build
something like this out of forum which
could be a very interesting thing we can
do in the future
any other question okay thank you